stop trying to get rich get better and
if you get better getting rich will
happen as a consequence getting rich is
an outcome getting better is an input
most entrepreneurs are focused on the
output as the thing and so they're
scattered in terms of where their focus
is because they're just trying to do
everything they can to drive this number
up rather than trying to do the thing
that creates the wealth I see a lot of
small business owners circling around
asking the same question which is
figuring out how they're going to scale
and your almost all doing it the wrong
way John Paul deorio said you don't want
to be in the selling business and
everything that I described at this
point is very much the selling business
and so the only way that you can grow
that business is selling more units is
selling more customers and that's a very
terrible business to be in and that's
also the business that 95% of businesses
are in is they're constantly struggling
for leads they constantly are trying to
figure out where my next customer is
coming from and if this is you then
listen to what I am saying right now if
your goal to grow your business is you
say okay I sell books great I sell books
in order for me to grow my book business
I have to get more people to buy my book
and that's it period Well if you do that
um there's you literally just have to
Market and sell for the rest of your
entire life and the only way to grow
your business is to advertise more
that's literally it the only way to grow
and so unless you're supremely good at
advertising and you learn how to master
Affiliates you learn how to master SEO
you learn how how to master making
content you learn how to run paid ads
you learn how to do email you learn how
to do outbound right you learn how to do
all these things so that you can
maximize your sales unless you do that
and the thing is is and this is what
sucks is that the next month you have to
reload all of your sales again you have
to start at zero again and that sucks
and that's how the vast majority of
businesses live but the thing is it
doesn't have to be that way you have to
look at the back of the business and say
why are there so many holes in my bucket
because just pouring more water into the
holy bucket like everyone understands
this conceptually but we don't act that
way and I say this from experience
because in the earlier part of my career
I only chased revenue and I chased
profit I just wanted I wanted growth at
all costs but the thing is is that
sometimes the cost of that growth is the
long-term growth of the business and so
it's like you sacrifice the long-term
growth so that you can grow faster in
the short term and so big picture what
what you what you want to do is figure
out something that people don't stop
buying and I feel like I say this over
and over again but like no one does it
and so it doesn't have to be a recurring
business model you just have something
that people either tell their friends
immediately about so like in the book
instance we sell almost a million
dollars a month in books I don't
advertise the books right and it's
because people read it and then they
post about it they tell their friends
and then other people buy the book and
that that Circle goes on it's because we
spent more time on the product and it's
the sandwich shop that's like I have to
sell more customers into my sandwich
shop but their sandwiches are just
mediocre and so they're going to be
stuck forever trying to figure out what
the new Hook is and to be fair I wrote a
book on offers and I think that's
important when you're getting started
but long term the offer just gets them
in the door how well you deliver on the
offer is what's going to keep them
paying over and over again it's going to
get them to send referrals I'll tell you
a story so I had a friend of mine
started a cookie business and when he
started the cookie business this is what
he did he went around the country to the
top cookie stores and chefs or Bakery
chefs I don't know what they're called
Bakers and he asked them if he could
just hang out with them and learn how
they bake their cookies and they were
you know some of them said you know
pound sand but some of them were like
sure you can hang out and so he learned
what they did to bake cookies and then
when he came back home he baked a new
dozen cookies every single day for a
year and he numbered all the batches and
he had 365 batches of cookies and every
time he did it he gave it to Tasters and
then people would say you know what I
like this I don't like this whatever and
so by the end of that time period when
he opened his restaurant guess what also
happened the many people who had tasted
his cookies he got their numbers he was
giving free cookies away so that he
could figure he also generated leads
from his area and then he opened and had
a a a smashing success of a business
selling premium cookies in a local
market which is a tough business to be
in but he crushed it and he did it
because he spent 365 days doing the work
to figure out the hundred tiny details
that make a perfect cookie and so like
if you're in the sandwich business if
you're in the SEO business if you're in
the in the mechanic business it's
figuring out what we need to do to make
the cookie that much better and that's
the work that no one's willing to do and
that's the good news is that's the
opportunity that's the opportunity that
most people aren't willing to do they're
always like if you ask small business
owners what do I need they say I need
more leads they all say that now if if
everybody says they need the same thing
to me that's a big light bulb that if
they're all pursuing the same thing and
none of them are growing then they're
probably looking for the wrong stuff and
if you've been stuck at the same level
for a long period of time listen to what
I'm saying right now you have to find
out why people aren't buying again you
have to find out why people aren't
referring their friends and sometimes
you're like well when I ask them they
don't tell me it's like sometimes you
have to read between the lines and
that's the hard part but that's the work
like that's the
work and I get I get I get I get a
little bit peeved about this because I
see so many small business owners that
aren't growing and they're not growing
because they're always thinking about
how they're going to get more leads but
they're not realizing the fact that they
have to get more leads because they have
so many holes in their bucket and so
there is a level advertising that you
have to maintain in order to test my
friend with the cookie store had to go
out to people and he had to get them to
try the cookies but the objective once
he had his second batch of cookies
wasn't like oh I need to give out you
know 12 batches a day no that wasn't the
goal at that point the goal was to
refine the product refine the service
make it better get the onboarding the
recruiting the hiring the training of
the employees so they could deliver the
service good enough so that when he
scaled the quality of the product remain
the same or ideally had a process in
place that that it would improve over
time but people rush to scale because
they have some sort of insecurity about
I have to make progress but the thing is
not all progress is measured in Revenue
immediately some progress happens at a
delay and so one of the biggest progress
markers that happens at a delay is
product and so when we talk about
delayed gratification one of the ways
that you can exercise that muscle of
learning to delay reward for the work
you do is improving the thing that you
deliver because if you improve your
sales you're going to immediately see a
jump if you improve your Le you'll
immediately see a jump and that's why it
gets so addicting for small business
owners because they say oh look I
improved this little sales thing and
look we're making more money and yes you
are making more money but the thing is
is that you're not going to make the big
money the monster money comes from the
back end the reason you can't afford
your leads there's never not enough
leads I like I want to impress this upon
you there is an unlimited amount of
traffic in the world across all media
you've got radio you've got newspaper
you got direct mail you've got you've
got Instagram you've got Facebook you've
got YouTube You've Got Tik Tok you've
got you've got Spotify ads right you've
got podcasts you've got Affiliates
you've got there's SEO there's so many
different places where eyeballs are the
problem is not that you don't have
enough leads the problem is you can't
afford them because your product sucks
like this is the problem and so you have
to build it back to front you can
consistently think about this from a
competitive Mo perspective if you make
the same amount of money per customer as
your competition then you are always
going to be in a race to the bottom and
when I say race to the bottom I mean a
race to the bottom of CAC you want to
all you're going to be doing is trying
to find little hacks to to hack social
media to hack ads to do whatever and
those hacks are always
short-lived the biggest businesses and I
look at this a lot because I spent a lot
trying to trying to think okay how's
Alex going to get to a billion how's
Alex get to 10 billion is I look at the
biggest companies and the thing is is
that have you noticed that the biggest
companies aren't doing the Instagram
hacks have you noticed they're not
trying to do these little like oh yeah
if you put this hashtag at the bottom
like oh if you do this little call out
or the shout out like if you noticed
that they don't do
that and the reason they don't do that
is because they don't have to because
they have won the long game and the long
game is the LTV game it's how much is a
customer Worth to me and so Dan Kennedy
said this a long time because he who can
spend the most to a Car customer wins
and I rephrase that as he who can make
his customers the most valuable
wins because being able to spend the
most is a product of how much you make a
customer worth to you which is a
function of what the gross profit is and
how many times they buy and the how many
times they buy function has a direct
proportion to how good the quality of
the product is and by the way when you
improve the quality of your product
guess what happens you get referrals now
think about this I want to again we have
to play this out two three
steps if you start
marketing let me tell you some truths
that will not change advertising will
always become more
expensive the cost per eyeball will
always go up you look at cpms on
Facebook you look at cpms on YouTube the
costs per eyeball always always go up on
every
platform and as you scale your
advertising will go to colder and colder
audiences and it will become less and
less efficient this happens at scale
these are truths these will not change
these are facts and so if you want to
scale a business how can you scale if
there have two things that are going in
a linear Direction against you the cost
of advertising to reach the eyeball goes
up and the conversion percentage of
those eyeballs also goes up because you
go to a bigger and bigger audience that
knows less and less they're less problem
aware and you have less product aware
and you have to do more education up
front to a less interested audience this
happens this is an
inevitability and so how do you combat
that one of the cool ways that you can
increase LTV for almost any business is
actually building a community around
your business and so I just became
coowner of
school.com and you can go there and we
have facilitated and made super super
easy getting a community built and
monetized and thriving and so whether
you want to start a community business
which is you know one type of person or
you're already a business owner um it's
a great way to increase the LTV of your
customers provide more value to them and
have one place that you can always
disseminate all your information all
your announcements to them to continue
to extend the LTV and you can go to
school.com games or just school.com and
you can start for free you combat that
by having referrals and referrals come
from every sale and so if every sale one
that person keeps buying and two they
send you another customer guess what
happens that cat gets cut in half and so
you need an equally strong compounding
vehicle that works in your favor to
maintain your lcvd CAC ratio and so when
you improve product you also decrease
CAC via referrals at scale so it doesn't
matter how much scale you have if you
deliver an exceptional product you will
be able to have you always know that 1.3
customers or every customer brings you
you know whatever3 new customers on top
of that so you decrease your cost
require by 30%
and you get the LTV boost that happens
on the back end as well which is that
they buy more and they they spend longer
they're willing to pay a premium and so
forth and the third third wheel of that
in terms of product is that product is
the end of the brand cycle so if you
think about brand is a reinforcing Loop
right in the beginning when you start a
company you make a promise fundamentally
that's how you enter Marketplace you say
I'm going to solve this problem that is
my promise to you all right and anyone
can say that what builds the business
over the long term is your ability to
deliver on that promise otherwise it's
the same reason you see all these
[__] internet marketers who change
Who start a new a new business every 6
months and the new businesses they're
like I got to find the next offer
because they're so frontend obsessed
because they never figure out what was
wrong with your first offer people
bought it the problem is you couldn't
deliver on it and so just little Vegas
Warning Sign by the way if you see the
same guy changing up his offer every 6
months is because he doesn't know how to
keep his promises he lacks the skill of
product he lacks the skill of delivery
he lacks the skill of being able to
recruit hire and manage a team that can
deliver consistently he lacks that skill
and so honestly what happens to that
person over time their reputation gets
degraded you start saying this guy's a a
h a has been he he's washed up all he
does is promote new stuff he's a shill
he just sells whatever is hot and many
of you are that
person and so you keep trying to find
new ways to get leads when you can't
keep your
promises if you keep your promises and
you put all your focus there your CAC
will go down it will continue to go down
and that's what's crazy is that the more
you do that the more you reinforce the
brand Loop because you make a promise
you keep that promise and then the
people you keep the promise to tell
other people you kept the promise and
then that decreases your ca the inverse
of that and this is there's a there's a
quantitative test for this if you run
advertisements and your cost to acquire
customer increases at a faster rate than
the average cost of cpms the cost per
impression in your market then it means
you have Word of Mouth working against
you think about this everyone
understands positive word of mouth we
all get that right we're like oh yeah I
get referrals did you know that you have
far more negative referrals you have way
more detractors you have way more people
that when they see an ad of your
business what do they do they reach out
to other people to ask about you and
then then people who would have
purchased choose not to based on
information they get online or asking
someone they
know and so your conversion rate
decreases over time you complain that
ads aren't working when in reality all
of this is the Invisible Hand of your
product sucking I get passionate about
this because I just I see it so many
times and it's the thing that that keeps
you stuck and so the only way to combat
this is to become a worldclass marketer
and just only know how to sell [__] and
hey if you're selling to a really big
Market I'm going to be honest with you
there's a lot of really big name
marketers that the only reason they make
money is because they sell to the ocean
of humanity and they only need one
transaction and they spend all of their
trying time trying to Arbitrage media as
in they know what their cost per
impression is they know how much they
make and they just Jam as much as they
can in there but that's not a business
that is a cash flow job that you get
really good at with that skill but
that's also why marketers have terrible
reputations building a brand is in my
opinion the good side of marketing and
the brand is simply the associations
that people have with your product and
if those associations are positive then
you build that reputation you build that
positive Association and that takes
time but if you make the brand your end
goal then you will be able to charge
higher prices than other people for the
exact same thing and people will
purchase from you because from a value
equation perspective their perceived
likelihood of achievement goes up their
risk associated with the purchase in
terms of what they believe their ease
and the ease of achieving what they're
going to get goes up and even if your
time delay is slower they have so much
conviction that you're going to deliver
on your promise that they're willing to
pay the
premium and so your cost to acquire
customers goes down at scale brand
driven advertising is more profitable
than the pure scammy direct response
stuff
it just takes
longer but the Raz is insane it's not
like 2x 3x it's like 30 100x it's way
bigger and that's how companies like
apple print money they print money look
at their marketing spin they print money
because they have a line of customers
that bought their last product and just
by knowing that they have a good
reputation of delivering on their
promises they buy the next one and so
I'll tell you a story that happened for
the one of the probably the first time I
really saw this was when I was uh when I
I was probably a year into gym launch
we're ripping and roaring right in terms
of scale and you know everyone's just
printing money using the system that we
had right and I launched something
called uh I think I called it LNS at the
time which was like lead nurture system
something like that I can't remember
what I what I called it but basically it
was we no aln it was automated lead
nurture that's what it was aln and so I
did this big webinar I did this big
launch and because gym owners are
business owners there was a number of
them that couldn't make it on the live
but they heard that I had sold told this
thing the amount of people that reached
out after the webinar not having seen
the webinar and said hey here's my
credit card number whatever it is just
give it to me I I if if he launched it I
know it's good I had never had that
happen in my life and I was like how do
I never stop this from happening again I
want this to always be my norm and it
reinforced so strongly how important it
was to keep your promises and so there's
there's a relationship that I think is
missed a lot especially in the the info
and online space and I want to hit on
this but it applies to all businesses is
that there's three lines that you have
to keep in touch with you have the price
that you charge you have the value that
they get and then you have the cost
associated with delivering the thing and
so you want these lines to be as far
apart as humanly possible all of them
you want them to be spread out super
super far you want to have crazy high
value at the top you want a price that's
a premium and then you want to have a
lot of juice left over relative to your
cost and the way to get that kind of
space between your cost and your price
is to do the work of the hundred details
that your competitors aren't willing to
do they're not willing to find out that
when someone walks in the restaurant if
we just we find out what their name is
at the car we can greet them by name
small thing right and we have the
waitresses all write down on the on the
on the on the receipt what their name is
and say thanks for coming in ow
whatever right and we try to make sure
that they all get their Waters within 30
seconds of sitting down we make sure
that they get their bread within 2
minutes we make sure that but we check
in every five or every 10 or whatever
we've tested has been the right amount
and maybe it maybe it comes down to
asking the customer up front hey is this
something do you want like do you want
me to come like is this a fast dinner or
is this something you want to kind of
like juice and enjoy I will I will match
your Cadence maybe simply asking the
question draws attention to the fact
that you care it might not even matter
what you do but maybe simply asking the
question improves their experience and
so it's these 100 BBS no silver bullets
that the good news is that your
competition is lazy as [__] it's so easy
think about how many business like I do
business with a lot of businesses on a
personal level on a business level I
would not recommend most of them and the
thing is is that those vendors think
that I'm an amazing customer I'm I'm a
hair away from being a detractor and
many of you have customers that are a
hair away from being attracted sometimes
you got customers who pay for your thing
and still tell people not to buy
it my pool guy when I had a pool I don't
have a pool anymore but when I had a
pool that guy was so inconsistent he
didn't clean stuff all the time i' I'd
walk out afterward be like what what did
he even did he even do anything this
week right but I still paid because it
was just such a hassle to change but I
was Absolut attracted when my neighbor
like oh yeah who's your pool service I'm
like don't use my guy I just don't have
time to find somebody else they're like
oh thanks and and that small business
owner is like man I have such a great
business like
and like we'd have gym owners who
thought that their their gyms were hot
[__] and then somebody opens up across
the street and literally takes all their
customers what they didn't realize is
the main reason people went to their gym
is it was just
convenient they thought all of their
workouts they thought all of their music
they thought they thought the the the
the layout of the gym the equipment
there they thought all that was
important but the thing that mattered
most was that you just happened to be
the only gym in a 5 mile radius of this
spot and so a lot of times the thing
that the reason that you're winning you
don't even know why you're
winning and so professional uh Professor
berglan from Stanford said this he said
it's better to know why you have failed
than to succeed and not know why and I
always I think that's a very profound
statement because for us as business
owners we we're always willing to
attribute negative things to outside
forces right we're always willing to say
oh you know Co happened my business got
hurt or whatever right the economy is
bad credit rates are compressing
but we aren't willing to give outside
forces the credit for when we do well
we're like oh no that was me that was
that marketing initiative oh yeah that's
cuz we've been really working on the
team it might just be nothing to do with
you at all and so understanding what are
the drivers that actually drove the
success are some of the things that you
have to find out that your competition
doesn't know so many business owners
just believe in mythology they just they
just make up narratives around why
they're successful and they have no way
to prove it one of the things that I see
people just melt in front of me when I
ask they're like well this is uh you
know they basically tell me a story
about their business they say well
people don't do that because and then
they insert some make belief thing and I
say how do you know
that and then they just look at me like
how do you know that they don't they've
never measured
it I had a vendor recently uh who was
like hey we need to do this this and
this uh with uh with something on media
and I was like okay why he was like well
this is going to create more growth and
I said how do you know that
and then he gave me another stat and
that stat was derived from the first
stat that he said to increase he said
when this increases this increases I was
like no [__] do you know how math
works of course of course it does now to
be clear I don't think this was out of
malice to be very clear but no one
thinks and the good news is your
competition doesn't think
either and so if you want to win you
just need to stop like whenever someone
gives you a because statement in your
team just ignore it and if they do give
it to you
and you in and you insist on trying to
listen to it then say how do you know
that and most of the time they're like
well you know gut feel like your gut
feelings me nothing to me if you haven't
tracked it and you have no data to
support it then you I can make up things
too when you hear podcasts of of of
business people and they're telling you
the things that work for them the crazy
thing is that most of the time they
don't know either and so this is what
drives me nuts people are like hey Alex
do you think that you know having a hard
childhood even having a troubled
relationship with your father I don't
we're fine right but do you think that
is the reason that you're so driven I'm
like I don't
know how would I know I know that I am
driven there's OB zillion things that
have happened to me in my life I don't
know which one it is but we create these
narratives around it to believe it and I
and I'm and I'm I'm bringing this kind
of conceptual idea because right now
many of you are creating stories that
you tell yourselves to make yourself
feel better about why your product isn't
as good as it should be but you have an
excuse that only you need to believe and
you believe that excuse so it excuses
you from working harder on the stuff you
know you should be doing but aren't and
that that work the work you know you
should be doing but aren't is the
opportunity because that is the work
that your competitors also aren't doing
and I'm telling you from the bottom of
my soul it is so easy to beat people
today they are so soft they have no work
ethic no one can stick with anything
everyone's distracted they're on social
media they're their [__]
notifications because they can't stick
with [__] they can't say no and so
sometimes you got to say hey guys we're
going to stay at this Revenue level
until we get referrals over
30% we're going to stay at this Revenue
level we're going to stay at this level
of advertising because I don't want
anyone else to know how mediocre our
sandwiches are why would I tell anyone
else I don't want anyone to know if I
could test this with no one knowing I
would do it but we have to advertise a
little bit so we can fix our thing but
the point of that first phase of growing
the business because you start making
sales is to get better not to get
rich the point in the first phase is to
learn not to earn if I started a new
cleaning business tomorrow the first
year would just be trying to nail the
model I wouldn't be I wouldn't be
thinking about what we're growing every
I wouldn't care I would only be focused
on how can we make this experience so
that no one leaves and that's all my
obsession is because I know that once
that happens whether you sell One
customer a month or five customers a
month or 10 customers a month your
business will not stop
growing if you do not lose customers
your business will not stop growing and
so while every one of your competitors
are looking for cheaper leads and trying
to find the new place where they get do
their little hacky Instagram thing you
can sleep well at night knowing I sold
10 customers last month and this month
I'll sell another 10 but I'll have 20
and the month after that I'll sell 10
and I'll have 30 and the month after
that I'll send 10 and I'll have 40 and
we will just keep [__] growing
because I spent a year or two years or 5
years figuring out exactly what to do
that delivered for my customer and that
is the work that no one will do and that
is why entrepreneurship is much more a a
battle of wills than it is a battle of
intellect you have to be willing to
delay gratification for an extended
period of time and eat glass and that
eating of glass is seeing how many
failures you have until you get it right
and this is the difference between small
businesses and big businesses is their
willingness to put put up with that long
period of time of getting the product
right and then once you get it right you
can scale to the Moon because you will
make more than everyone else on your
back end you will deliver on your
promises your brand will be reinforced
with every sale rather than degraded
with every sale and then at scale you
will continue to be able to acquire
customers profitly because you have a
force that is compounding which is the
referral base of customers that tells
other people how good your stuff is
while also continuing to purchase
themselves so in Silicon Valley they
have a saying which is you know break
break things move fast I think that was
one of Facebook's early you know values
um that break fast and move stuff is
building back to front that is building
the product through iteration so that
you can have extended LTV so that you
can have the activation of users so that
because fundamentally think about this
way if Facebook did not get users
activated and they were like we need to
spend more on marketing so we can get
more users it would never work at scale
it has to have a compounding vehicle
built within the business and the
compounding vehicle in the business for
most businesses is the quality of their
product that is the compounding vehicle
you have to get people to continue to
buy or continue to use in Facebook's use
in in Facebook's case and so they have
to think about how can we eliminate
friction in a hundred different ways so
that we can make it smoother I mean this
is what we work on at school all the
time is how can you make this easier how
can we make this faster how can you make
this more streamlined so that anybody
can be successful with it in most small
business owners fix one or two things
and then they immediately want to scale
they want to gas the advertising to make
more sales and the problem with that is
that it does this so you increase sales
and so by percentage growth it'll be
really aggressive and it starts slowing
down and you can always tell growth of
businesses like this especially at the
1030 $100 million Mark and they're not
even close to their total addressable
Market because the only way they grew is
through jamming sales and marketing not
through having a product that compounded
and so that is the big difference
between massive multiples in companies
when you to sell for 20x 50x you know
massive numbers because the person who's
acquiring it has no doubt that that
business will continue to compound and
grow if the business is purely based on
Marketing sales then they know that it's
only as good as it's last month and if
the marketing director leaves or or
their their sales channel gets shut down
then the business is going to rapidly
Decline and so not not only does it make
the company significant more valuable it
also makes life a lot more chill as an
entrepreneur because you know that this
month like last month like two years ago
the customer you bought you sold two
years ago put that all that effort in
they're still buying today improving
your product is the highest leverage
thing you can do because every single
person gets that product and so you work
on it one time and then it's you know
cut cut once sell 100 times cut once
sell a thousand times whereas marketing
is a is a linear relationship you have
to go market more to get more customers
but if you continue to improve the
product that thing can get you 100 times
more customers or massively increase LTV
and so you get a disproportionate return
on the effort you put in on making your
thing better than you do on getting more
customers chunking up what we're
tracking with product is the price that
we're able to command for our services
or our product the number of recurring
purchases that we have from somebody so
if you have a reoccurring business it's
average number of orders that someone's
going to make with your business over a
lifetime or it's the churn associated
with your subscription or membership and
so these give you the quantitative
outputs of a highquality product but the
inputs are going to be closer to what
are their activation metrics like what
is and the way that you look at this is
you you do something called a regression
analysis around okay let's look at the
cohort of customers that don't cancel
because there is hopefully some
customers that don't leave you and you
look at what things occurred in and you
have to look at a lot of variables of
what things occurred uh in those
customers that haven't occurred in other
customers and then once you find those
things that occurred those become
activation points or at least your first
guess at activation points and then what
you do is you drive your onboarding
towards that activation Point some
people got a retention point and then
you remeasure again and so if you know
that once people you know achieve a sale
from SEO for your agency that the likely
the cancel goes down precipitously then
all of your effort for onboarding is how
quickly can we get them a sale from our
SEO if it's for weight loss you find out
that somebody needs to lose seven pounds
in the first two weeks and if they lose
the weight then the lik that they
continue to stay is very high so then
you drive all of your activation your
arm boarding towards getting to that
point and so everything is about looking
at the people at the end looking at the
thing that preceded them getting to that
point and then putting all of your focus
on getting people to have that
experience at the most basic level I had
a first book and many people who bought
this book and liked it bought the second
book when it came out obviously we had a
launch but the thing is is that we still
sell thousands and thousands and
thousands and thousands of copies of
this book every single month and even
though this book is 2 and a half or
three years old or whatever it is this
still sells thousands and thousands and
thousands of copies every month because
there's also new people every month that
are getting into entrepreneurship or
want to learn about uh making better
offers for their business and so the
people who upsold between product one
and product two many of them saw nothing
besides the fact that they found out
that I had another book out and then
bought it and I don't say that in a
self-aggrandizing way I say that because
like I've lived the other way and it's
much better to do it this way and if
you're trying to increase LTV to have a
compounding business model then one of
the first things you need to do is do
the unscalable I made an entire video
about it go check it out it'll probably
help you out